joining me today is an entrepreneur a
venture capitalist and author the
co-founder of PayPal the first outside
investor in facebook the founder of
Palantir and Silicon Valley's ultimate
contrarian thinker Peter teal finally
welcome to the Rubin report David thanks
for having me on the show it's good to
be here with you I normally don't have
this many cards for a guest but I've got
a lot of cards for you today are you
ready to roll ready to go all right so
we have to start obviously Rogan had
Elan musk on last week last week and
they smoked a joint so do you want me to
put the joint on the table right now or
how are we doing this you know mine my
number one rule is never to compete with
the Elan man oh you know I would never I
would never bet against Elan it's it's
been like this I've been I was a close
partner of his at PayPal in the in the
late 90s early 2000s and and after
PayPal you know Ilan set out to start
these to the you know both the rocket
company and the the electric car company
SpaceX and Tesla yeah and I think the
conventional wisdom on Elon was these
were both completely harebrained
projects and if one of them had
succeeded that you have to sort of
question it and when both of them
succeeded it suggests that you know he
knows something people other people
don't all right well that is a matter of
luck
I'll keep I'll keep the joint right here
for a now don't compete with you on all
right but look that's a good place to
start because first you know it's
interesting because we've gotten to know
each other a little bit in the last
couple years and it seems to me that the
person that I know privately is sort of
different than the way the media
portrays you so I thought maybe at the
beginning let's just do a little history
about you and then we can get to some of
the controversies and some of the ideas
that you're really interested and things
like that so let's start with with
PayPal since you mentioned it already
where did the idea of PayPal first come
from well you know it's it's when you
start one of these companies uh it's
it's typically not the case that you get
the whole idea fully formed you know
instantaneously we certainly there was
this incredible internet boom going on
in Silicon Valley in the late 90s it
felt
there was sort of this open frontier
open Gold Rush
one of the natural things to look at was
you know was finance I I was sort of
very interested in the cryptocurrency
could there be new forms of money
there's always something you know super
mysterious powerful important about
money it was it was it was the way that
this this was going to change so we had
I think we had this general idea to do
something with security with money with
payments from very early on of the
founding of the company and then you
iterate a lot on how to how to get the
idea out and the the critical question
for any consumer internet product is
always not what the idea is but how do
you get it out how do you get the
distribution out and we spent there been
a lot of payments companies Internet
payments companies that already started
and failed by 1998 there was one called
when one called up other cyber cash
there were you know there's sort of a
variety of these different ones that had
tried to create these you know
comprehensive currency schemes and they
would work if everybody use them but you
could never get even the first person to
start but the challenge was how to make
it viral how do you get something to
work where it's good for the first
person for the tenth person to the 100th
person and once you have millions of
people you have a network you have
network effects and that was sort of the
chicken and egg problem yeah so how did
you guys overcome that hurdle
well we eventually stumbled on this idea
of linking money with email because they
were ready 300 million people in 99 that
had email accounts and and so if you
could send money to an email address you
know it send it to your email and then
you get an email saying you've received
cash and then you'd obviously click on
the links and do the work necessary to
get the money out and so and so you
didn't need both counterparts to a
transaction to be part of the PayPal
Network only the sender could be part of
it and then the recipient the recipient
would sign up as they took the money out
and and then we started with the 24
people in our office those were the
first 24 customers and they sent money
to friends and to other people but gave
these referral bonuses we gave you $10
who signed up
ten dollars you got something to sign up
and it just grew exponentially when we
were you know it grew about seven to ten
percent compounding daily and now if
you're you know and you start with a
small number if you can get seven to ten
percent daily compounding and after
about a month year at a thousand people
by those mid November of 99 by end of
December of 99 it was a twelve thousand
by February third two thousand was at a
hundred thousand by mid April two
thousand was up two million and so so
what did you do look in terms of getting
people to understand the way you could
work with money differently because I
actually remember the first time I used
PayPal I think it was in 2001 I was a
struggling comic I had moved into a
roommates little apartment because I
didn't have much money and I had but I
had to pay him a couple hundred bucks or
something a month for for rent and he I
was gonna give him a check he said
PayPal me and just the idea that I was
somehow linking my bank account to
something on the computer we didn't even
have I don't know if I'm not mistaken I
think I was still using dial-up I don't
even know that we you know had had Wi-Fi
or anything like that but it's about an
idea that this can even happen how did
you train people to realize well it's
this is something that's real and it's
always on its is it normally you serve
to get people start doing something like
that it has to be something where
there's an intense need and and maybe
it's not too dangerous and so the in one
the natural places that started was on
the eBay auction site where at small
dollar transactions maybe $40 the
typical amount and if you send check
across the country that's like a seven
to ten delay 10-day delay it's slow most
people aren't set up to process credit
cards you roommate probably couldn't
process credit cards and so and so you
know but since you could make PayPal
payments with a credit card you could in
fact send a credit card payment to 300
million people whereas they're only
something like three or four million
that are set up to process their like
hundred fifty million people with emails
in the u.s. at the time there may be
three million that were set up to
process credit cards small businesses
things like that so we expanded it by
you know 147 million do you remember
what it felt like as it started
compounding the way you're talking about
like what it was like
as it was growing and you realize like
wow we really have this well you are
you're new you're at the forefront of
like some sort of revolutionary thing it
it's incredibly exciting and it's
incredibly scary and it was a is like
going to take over the world we're all
gonna die and move several times between
you know that those two several times a
day yeah was there any bizarre pushback
from banks or any anyone that was doing
financial tradition that was
traditionally there were certainly like
more than more than our share of
challenges you had a you had an enormous
problem of fraud where people just
figured out ways to hack the system and
steal money mm-hmm and then and you
can't simply get rid of fraud because
you always get rid fought it and make it
cumbersome but it's easy then it's also
easy to defraud so your challenge was
how do you get it to be easy to use but
hard to defraud and that took it took
some time there on certainly banks
didn't like there were you know they're
all the the incumbent players that that
didn't like something new and then of
course it was sort of in this in this
strange regulatory zone where you know
was a new form of payments a new form of
moving money and and you know the way
often thought of it at the time was that
we were in a race between technology and
politics and you know the politicians
didn't like us but if we got the system
the PayPal network to be big enough it
would sort of overwhelm the regulators
and they'd have to accept it as a fait
accompli
so the libertarian party you must have
loved that concept like you were
actually doing something that
libertarians or suppose there was a
early 2000 conversation you know one of
the one of the execs at PayPal said that
you we need to hire a whole bunch of
lawyers else what we what we can do or
can't do else we can't do so we have to
just go ahead and not hire the lawyers
and just just do it yeah now you know
the the sort of uh I I actually I do not
know if a company like PayPal could have
been started even two three years later
so you know in the in the aftermath of
9/11 we got the Patriot Act in the US
and that that attached you know much
more regulatory scrutiny to to financial
transactions to payments that no your
customer rules became much much trickier
and so so I do think that there's a
weird way in which there was an opening
to start a business like PayPal
in 1999 2000 even three years later I
think it might not have been possible
yeah and it's so cool to me just knowing
a lot of your ideology and the
libertarian ideas you care about and
just going ahead and building what you
want to build instead of waiting for
other people to do it I mean you
actually did it and and that's a pretty
pretty great thing well it was it was um
it was sort of the sense that you know
we were gonna change the world we're
gonna know give people more control over
their money we had all these ideas about
you know getting rid of central banks
and creating a new currency we never
quite you know got to the Bitcoin ya
stage of it we'll get to that later but
but certainly certainly these ideas were
you know we're incredibly motivational
in doing it and it is always a little
bit of a contrast from you know I always
have this view on politics where it's
both you know incredibly important and
then in many ways incredibly frustrating
yeah as it's so on it's like the air we
breathe that permeates our whole system
and then it's also so hard to ever
change you know as a as a college
student I started you know this
conservative libertarian newspaper and
Stanford the stanford review and and
there's a lot and it's important to have
debates to discuss things and then it's
often so hard to change things indeed
the the PayPal hack was in a way and
we're gonna stain the world we're gonna
ask for permission yeah you know we're
just tech technology over politics well
speaking of changing the world let's
flash forward a couple years so we're
just doing some business background
first before we get to a lot of your
ideas of the day you were the first
outside investor in facebook 500 grand
to this Zuckerberg I did you know him
well before that had you guys
communicated a lot how did that even
come to pass
not really was the sort of actually
literally the first day we met we
thought wow he for an hour we came back
and we gave him the term sheet about an
hour later so it was how was it was a
fast decision I think I think people
always have the sort of Shark Tank image
of these things the exam sort of you
know super sophisticated pitch and you
could say just the right things right
that's what works and I was nothing of
the sort and he was a he was a you know
kind of introverted 19 year old you know
sophomore between sophomore junior year
summer summer too
2004 and and and the the main and and
and and and the main thing I'd going for
was it was just growing fast they were
they were at something like twenty
college campuses they had about a
hundred thousand people on the network
and they just needed more money for
computers because there was such a
demand for for the product is they were
gonna launch at more colleges in the
fall so as that would appeal to you more
than the product itself just that you
saw engagement was already it was
already working yeah um and then but I
would I would say the other the other
part of it was that there was like a
prehistory to it so one of my one of my
good friends from PayPal back from
Stanford's guy named Reed Hoffman
he started LinkedIn later years but and
he'd worked with me at PayPal in the
late 90s early 2000s but before that he
had started a social networking company
back in 1997
seven years before Facebook and they had
they already had you know they had
social net was the name of the company
so there's social networking in the name
of the company seven years before and
there were all these things that they
had they had thought about doing so I
was gonna be you know
it was gonna be you're on the 1990s
version of social networking was we're
gonna have these avatars in cyberspace
and I might be a cat and you might be a
dog and virtual cat you're a virtual dog
we have to figure out how we relate and
it turns out people aren't weren't
really interested in that they weren't
really interested in since of a
fictional an online persona it was much
more about real identity and and somehow
Facebook was the first one to crack the
problem of real identity where you know
even those always a little bit curated
certainly for the most part people on
Facebook are who they they say they are
yeah for the most part at least so am I
mistaken you're the only person who's
been on the board of Facebook the entire
way out except for mark right right
right since the beginning yes yeah what
can I ask you about that that Facebook
won't get too angry about if I ask you
well just what's the experience like of
being a but you're part of a board from
the beginning of really the thing of the
internet what seems to drive
conversation the most on the internet
well there's um you know there's I mean
it's it's been sir like this incredible
trajectory you know uh where it's it's
it's gotten probably much bigger than I
would have thought possible at the time
you know I was you know I was incredibly
optimistic and bullish on it's certainly
back in back in 2004-2005 I think that I
think that one one kind of perspective
for a lot of the world-class
entrepreneurs is they're not specialists
there there's something close to
polymaths and so you know if you have a
conversation with Mark Zuckerberg he'd
be able to speak you know with with you
know surprising amount of understanding
about a lot of things so we could speak
about the details of the Facebook
product you could talk about you know
the way people think about social media
the psychology the the way the culture
is shifting the management of the
company has ideas on that his ideas on
and then how this fits into the bigger
history of technology and so it's uh you
know it was sort of an academic view is
often that you're like a sort of a
narrow expert on one thing mm-hm and
that's what you do and and what it is
about it's it's much more sort of this
this polymath like intellect to
understand all these different things
the kinds of board conversations we've
had over the last you know 13 14 years
have it's just been this crazy range
yeah it must be particularly interesting
for you though as sort of the outsider
in Silicon Valley and we're going to
talk about you why you moved down to LA
and all that stuff that you've been
there the whole time that it's not you
know they didn't for all the reasons
that Silicon Valley may be what it is
you weren't ever booted off the board or
anything like that they've they've let
you be the contrarian guy there so that
that actually must that's a good thing
about Silicon Valley I suppose or at
least within the little microcosm that
you sit in right no I I you know I I
don't experience you know a great deal
of hostility to me personally you know
people you know it's it's it's you just
you you always you know it's it's it's
sort of manifests in all sorts of other
way so I do think Silicon Valley at this
point has a bit of a conformity problem
it has you know a bit of a way in which
people are
- too much all thinking the same way
it's just like the there was you know
the the Apple I saw this this meme on
the internet the other day where was
sort of the Silicon Valley 1997 : think
different that's the look in valley 2018
: think the same yeah and and so there
is something that's uh that's gone
that's gone a bit wrong even though you
know it's it's I'm hard-pressed to cite
things were you know it's really
affected me personally yeah all right
well I was actually gonna push that to a
little bit later but let's just stay
with that for now then do you remember
moments did you see some markers along
the way where you realized some of this
groupthink was affecting the actual
products where where the actual ability
to create new technologies or new
products where that was actually causing
stagnation because I sent I said it's
been sort of a long road to get here but
you have sort of been talking about this
for a while now and I think there's a
direct connection to the diversity myth
which we'll also talk about what you
wrote you know twenty years there great
right well I I do think Silicon Valley
has shifted a lot over over the years so
I was in an undergraduate at Stanford in
the late 1980s Stanford was sort of a
very liberal politically correct place
but the Silicon Valley surrounding not
so much it was vaguely libertarian you
know it was it was a moderate Republican
congressional district and and then so
by the late 90s I would say to shifted
to being sort of a moderate moderate
Democrat which is around the time I
started PayPal and he fast forward
another twenty years it's sort of it's
it's it's sort of a pretty hard left
yeah so what is it what do you think has
there because it seems to me that if I
was taking the people that I wanted to
be the most creative the most outside
the box the most to look at the system
and go how do we fix the system from the
outside you'd want a lot of libertarian
thinkers that's that's the way I would
at least look at it so you'd think that
everyone in Silicon Valley would be
pretty libertarian they want to do
things on their own and yet somehow in
those twenty years it became the Opera
well it's it's all I can only ask the
question why is it why is it so so long
I think these things are you know
there's somewhat over to term
so I would say part of it is on is that
it's probably the most educated part of
the country in terms of how much time
people spent in college mm-hmm and I
think one of the downsides of too much
education is that you get the most
brainwashed and so it's it's it's the
most educated can also mean that it is
it is the it is the most brainwashed you
know this is perhaps not so true of the
founders but certainly of of many of the
the rank-and-file people who are on you
know if you're sort of like a really
good engineer or you know really good at
some specific thing your education
typically does not involve you thinking
that much about about politics and so
it's not necessarily from deep
ideological conviction it's often more
as a fashion statement than as a
question of of power and so and so one
of the things it's always a little bit
hard to score is that even if you took a
survey in Silicon Valley it's it's it
comes out as you know quite far to the
left
you know weirdly uniform weird sort of
groupthink it's super hard to know
whether people really believe this or
whether they're whether they're just
going along or so I I think it's pretty
liberal but but of course not as liberal
as it looks and that's that's in a way
worse because it means people are too
scared to articulate things right it was
a there was a dinner I had at my house a
week before the 2016 election with a
group of sorts of center-right Silicon
Valley people one of them was uh is a
very prominent angel investor in Silicon
Valley and he said you know I'm voting
for Trump in a week but because I live
in Silicon Valley I'm lying about it and
so he's saying this to you but told full
people there yeah and and avenges who's
honest about why it's unusual is a
little bit unusual
yeah and and the way I lie is I tell
people I'm voting for Gary Johnson the
libertarian so it's like you couldn't
you couldn't quite get away telling
people that he was voting for Hillary
Clinton because about your facial
muscles wouldn't work and tell that your
line is so small I Gary Johnson that was
sort of what you what you could do yeah
and and I think you know if you sort of
looked at what happened in the weeks
before the election
the Gary Johnson support sort of
collapsed it all went to trump mm-hmm
and the the question you have to ask is
whether did those people just change
their minds the last minute or were they
lying all along or were they lying to
themselves and and so I think the the
sort of political correctness you know
it's always bad for thought but it
always makes things appear more uniform
than they are even in Silicon Valley
yeah well I think you know this I said I
was gonna vote for Gary Johnson and I
did vote for Gary Johnson and as I
always say I should be judged
accordingly but here we are so this is
actually a perfect segue then to the
diversity myth because 20 years ago
you're you're at Stanford and you saw a
lot of the problems that we are talking
about today over and over again I I told
you a couple months ago I was listening
on c-span to a talk you gave about the
diversity myth and again it's from about
I think at that point it was like 18
years ago or something and I was
listening to it and David walked into
the room and he said who is that talking
because it was all true and it was he
thought it was somebody I would he
thought I was listening to the news of
today like somebody laying out what's
going on today but you saw this this
issue with multiculturalism with faux
diversity the focus on equality of
outcome not opportunity you saw all this
way before seemingly anyone did have how
did that come to be well it was there
was certainly quite a wave of this stuff
in the late 80s early 90s on you know a
number of college campuses and for a
variety of reasons on you know a lot of
it crystallized at Stanford there was a
there was this there was this super
intense debate about a Western culture
which was both a freshman one year long
freshman sort of general humanities
course where you learned about you know
Western culture history Western
civilization but then it was a course
and the and the reserve jesse jackson
showed up at campus went one day and
sort of led this chant hey hey ho ho
western cultures gotta go and people
were talking about both the course and
of course the whole society and culture
that was represented by that and and and
then and and so there were a lot of
these different debate
that God got sort of thrown up so is it
you know was concerned about
discriminant racial discrimination
gender discrimination you know other
kinds of people who are victimized and
then and then in many cases it felt like
it was this incredible overreach where
people were in some sense using their
victim status as a stick with which to
beat other people up or something like
that or and we're going to now victimize
the victimizers and it's gonna be sort
of something like that and and so
multiculturalism and political
correctness were somehow very linked the
the multiculturalism part was we're
gonna give special privileges you know
to disadvantaged people or gonna somehow
correct he's in justices of the past and
the politically the intolerant
politically correct part was we were
gonna go after their oppressors whether
they were real or imagined and in many
ways it felt like you know incredible
overreach you ended up with with these
draconian speech codes on campus and and
with with sort of the humanities in a
sense effectively got gutted in the late
80s at Stanford of course it took you
know many years for that to fully play
out but and then then of course one of
the buzz words then is now was diversity
which which and and you know I think I
think diversity is a good thing I think
especially you know diversity of ideas
mmm-hmm is to be valued but you don't
have real diversity when you just have a
group of people who look different and
and think alike and so it has to me it
has to be more than just you know than
just having the extras from the space
Cantina see something like that right
and and that's and so that's always
that's always so it's always like an
internal critique the diversity myth is
that it's not about diversity at all
it's about it's about conformity was
that the first time that you had really
staked out what is seemingly an
unpopular position although I think
actually especially in 2018 is is quite
a popular position even if it's thought
of as as out there was that the first
time you would publicly because nobody
wants to be the guy that says
stuff and then immediately is gonna be
called a racist and a bigot and a
homophobe all those things have you ever
done anything like that before you know
it's it's uh you know I probably you
know and it's it's hard to know how far
to go back in the pre heated
biographical sphere how good I am at
this but but probably already in a
junior high school high school I would
you know I would you know I would take
the positions that I believed in and
they wouldn't they wouldn't necessarily
be the majority positions and so it was
you know in it you know in you know
junior high school I was totally against
drug legalization of any sort and that
was a minority that was a minority view
war I
I supported Reagan in 1980 and you know
you know we were sort of a relatively
liberal area that was again sort of a
minority view so so I think I I would
have had I wouldn't say like extreme
outlier positions but but I've I've
always thought that it was an important
thing for yourself yeah so when you
wrote the book and then started talking
about these issues what kind of pushback
did you get because that I think is the
core issue that most of my viewers are
identifying with these days that they're
taking positions that are true that
don't mean that they're racists or
bigots or homophobes but that they mean
they care about more about diversity of
ideas than diversity of skin color or
those things and and they're scared to
say those ideas and yet you were doing
it a long time ago well it's it's it's
always a it's always a very tricky thing
so it's it's it's on some level on some
level the way we've just been talking
about it there aren't that many people
who will will go out of the way to
disagree with us so people know you know
the people I mean there's some people
but mostly we're gonna say you know
we'll find out we know don't we we don't
want any different views or you know we
just suppress views people some people
say that but not not really that many
right well they mask it in other ways
right no one's gonna outright say but
then but then in practice yeah you end
up with this with this with this
incredible conformity even though that's
not in theory what people what people
want not one of the one of the
professor's I studied under at Stanford
is Rene Girard is for this cultural
philosopher literary theorist is really
brilliant guy he sort of always had this
mimetic theory that people imitate each
other they copy each other they're sort
of they're much more prone to fashion
and things like this and uh and one of
them he was used from France and so one
of the one of the metaphors he had for a
lot of the sort of more politically
correct professors at Stanford was that
they all thought they were in the French
Resistance but but if they had lived in
Vichy France they would have all been
collaborators huh and and and so the the
the self understanding people have is
that they're super courageous
independent thinkers and that's why they
and and and and and that they would have
been in the resistance in France but
then in reality if you ask them what the
views are that they have it's the same
as everybody else around them yeah well
that's right
and you have to always ask if everyone
has the same views it can mean one of
two things it can mean that you've
reached the absolute truth or it can
mean that that you have you have this
sort of incredible conformity
yeah well it's so interesting because he
was talking about the resistance in
France and now we have a group of people
in America that think that they're part
of the resistance and I suspect that if
they were in power they would be
treating the people who were the the
resistance of them much worse than
they're being treated right
well III thought that the the Girard
critique could also apply to them that
that you know by identifying yourself as
part of you know some mob like
resistance movement you're you're
suggesting the exact opposite
yeah that you know it counts you know
political views you know I respect you
know I think there are people can have
sincere views even if they're in the
overwhelming majority but it's it's
impressive if you're in the minority so
if you're if you're speaking out against
President Trump in your small town in
Alabama I think that's a person yeah if
you're if you're in if you're in San
Francisco or Manhattan and and you're
part of the resistance
I I suspect something very different
it's go so that's
like what like a different word getting
at this is uh is it's you know in a
democracy we always think the majority
is right so it's 51 and 49 and 51 is
probably right if it's a big majority
it's even more right so 70/30 even even
more right but if it's a hundred to zero
99 to one that's that's what we start to
suspect that it will not in a democracy
but we're in North Korea or that
something's gone wrong with a voting
machine or something like this and so
when we have these sort of hothouse
environments at places like Stanford or
Silicon Valley where you have this
complete um you know uniformity of
thought the thing you have to suspect
that's not the wisdom of crowds it's not
that everyone's figured out the truth
it's a madness of crowds it's some
psychosocial insanity yeah and this
seems to be directly linked to what's
going on on our campuses today right I
mean if if twenty years ago you had been
thinking these things do you think your
prediction would have been oh we'll be
able to break these ideas enough so that
the the class of teachers and professors
may not be so addicted you know it seems
to it seems to have come back with a
vengeance on college or even even you
know radicalized further but but again
it it's you know this is sort of this is
like it's a it's a it's a subtle you
know you don't want to always
psychologize people you disagree with
but but the question when you look at
what's happening on campuses or in
various places is always is this really
what people think or is it just are they
just under you know incredible peer
pressure to fit in yeah do you see that
as a bizarre direct connection to the
way many other institutions seem to be
crumbling now the way people don't trust
the media the way they used to the way
that we're just seeing sort of a new you
know Alan on Rogen last week you're
sitting here today the way that people
want different conversations we're gonna
sit here for as long as it need to do
all that people can see through it yeah
they can they can see through the
manufactured consent they can see they
can you know it's it's if you have
conformity and it and it looks real
that's powerful if it if it's conformity
in people's sense that it's force
that's that's a lot shake here and so
there's it's it's sort of like I don't
know it's like the I'm not sure what the
right metaphor is but it's like maybe
maybe it's like you know The Wizard of
Oz where you have the man behind the
curtain and we're looking at the men
behind the curtain on the internet and
and that it doesn't quite work and you
know I think our sort of media political
machine maybe maybe it always worked
when people didn't understand how it
works is okay
you sort of see what's going on the
sausage-making Factory you know you
might not want eat as much sausage
anymore yeah all right well this is
clearly gonna be a theme to almost
everything else we talked about so let's
let's sort of catch up to where you are
today and then we're gonna go back to
some of that stuff I tell me a little
bit about Palantir well this was a this
was another company I started in in 2004
it was sort of the big picture the big
picture were PayPal was sort of to
revolutionize money and payments the big
picture for pound chancer like in the
wake of 9/11 a few years after that was
could one do something from a
libertarian or civil liberties point of
view that would still be you know tough
on terrorism and and and things like
this and and the sort of the sort of
sense I had was that that the way we
were going with just you know ridiculous
airport security checks and a super
intrusive surveillance all the time it
wasn't really making us safer yeah so
this was sort of you our answer to the
Patriot Act you know in a way this was
sort of you know it's like a yes you had
the ridiculous lines at airports he'd
been you know through all the ways that
you know the responsed
and and it was and there was a question
was there some way was there some
technological fix and you know one of
the ways I often think of technology is
that it's a way to do more with less and
and so you know you can you can get you
know you can get more energy for less
money that's like an energy innovation
and cleaner energy for you know less
pollution more energy that pollutes less
that would be like a technical
technology innovation and clean energy
and in the security space the doing more
with less is something
like is something like more security
with less intrusion on people's civil
liberties and that's kind of the that's
kind of the the trade-off that you want
and that the non technological debate
that we had in the US and 2004 in many
ways that we still have in 2018 is um
it's always it's always you do more with
more versus less with less so you can
have the neocon Cheney version let's say
would be that we're gonna have you know
we're gonna have you know more security
with more civil liberties violations and
then you can sort of say that they
equally Luddite ACLU would say something
like we're gonna have fewer you know
civil liberties violations and we're
gonna have less security right and and
that's kind of the that's the ayat the
way the ideological debate gets framed
you know I I'm sympathetic to the ACLU
on civil liberties but I think they will
always lose that debate because the way
you preserve civil dirties is not to
have terrorist attacks because when you
get a terrorist attack you get the
Patriot Act and you know if if the World
Trade Center would erode civil liberties
as much as it did in 2001 I didn't even
want to think what would happen if you
had another terrorist attack and so you
have to prevent it to to stop to stop
more erosion what Palantir does is is it
it sort of as a way for for for you know
patterns and data to be visualized
through a combination of computers and
human analysts and and then and then in
a way that doesn't simply scour the
planet and get all the information about
everybody so it's just if there's
something suspicious then you look some
more mm-hmm and and so there's sort of a
there's a natural predicate you build
before you investigate people and in
that sense it's it's way less intrusive
is this a tough position to hold just
because people seem all too eager to
give up their civil liberties like we
always want easy answers so that's why I
think the Patriot Act passed with two
dissenting votes if I'm not mistaken
that people don't
we act so emotionally all the time and
especially after a time like September
11th we were really I think out of whack
individually and collectively that you
can come in with a more sane answer and
say I understand civil liberties and I
don't want big government but I want us
all to be safe and that that's almost
doesn't ring for people because they
just want the easy answer they want the
bumper sticker answer yes yes I I think
it's it's not the easiest sell but but I
think there is certainly a lot more
awareness today about how much civil
liberties have been eroded you know how
we're living in this quasi surveillance
state all the time and how deeply
uncomfortable that is on so many levels
I think that I think that the way um you
know I think certainly if it worked if
the if the Luddite heavy-handed approach
has actually worked mm-hmm
then I think people people would be more
tolerant and then there's this sort of a
sense that they they don't even they
don't even work yeah is it hard to
define what work even means because
something could say work for three years
make sure everybody's safe even if it's
violating all sorts of personal privacy
and all that but then if there's an
attack then you oh well it doesn't work
well what work means you prevent
terrorist attacks from happening in the
but in the met narrow narrow so it's
just about the the window that it works
basically because the second it doesn't
work it doesn't work and well it's it's
it's it's how many you prevent that
would have otherwise happened yeah so I
mean it's it's it may be if it works
perfectly around all of them if it you
know works pretty well prevents most
yeah like that so this must be a little
bit of a tricky situation for you
because you obviously have to work with
the government on some of this stuff
right and I'm sure that that's probably
not thrilling for you at some level well
I look I I believe that I believe that
it's you know I I believe you can be
both a libertarian and and and work with
the government or even work for the
government or work in the government and
and even even if you believe that there
should be a much smaller much less
intrusive government you can still try
to work to make it fun
better and and and so there's both an
outside and inside game yeah you know
they'd all these versions like this so
it's like if you're libertarian should
you refuse to take a Social Security
check and well you can be against Social
Security and still personally collect a
check I'm pretty sure I ran to or a
charity if you're you know if you're
libertarian should you refuse to be a
public schoolteacher because you're the
government well maybe maybe it's
actually better to be a public
schoolteacher red ants on the socialist
person who otherwise get it it by
default so right I think I think I think
we can we can have certain kinds of
principles and then and then act in in
pragmatic ways and this isn't
necessarily hypocrisy you once said to
me and I'm sure you've said it to other
people that I wouldn't be a libertarian
if it worked
do you sort of picture a moment or do
you remember a moment where you think it
I guess basically big government stopped
working because it didn't work for a
while basically right not in our
lifetimes not or not very well in our
lifetimes mm-hmm I would say it's it's
easier to see with with with the benefit
of hindsight but I think yeah I used to
think you know when I was in college in
the 1980s I used to think that
libertarianism was a timeless and
eternal thing it was just these absolute
truths for all time all places in all
times mm-hmm and I've now come to think
that it's it can be sort of there's
certain context where it's more true or
less true and so if you have and if you
have incredibly well functioning
government political institutions
there's sort of you know less of a need
for libertarianism so you know in the
1950s or 1960s when the state of
California had first great public
schools across the board and if you said
well the government can't do anything
the public schools can't work there
might have been problems with them but
that what that argue have gotten a lot
less traction than it would today in
2018 right cuz you'd be the utopian
person at that point right yeah or you'd
be or you'd be - you'd be too
pessimistic obviously things things
things weren't that about horeshoe
theory I and and certainly or in the
military context we had a you know we
had the
you know the the atom bomb we had the
Manhattan Project we had the Apollo
space program in the 1960s where you got
a man on the moon so if you said the
government can't do anything that that
that felt somewhat wrong now III now I
think that I think the thing if we were
honest this is this is always the you
know somewhat disturbing thing is that
our government works much less well than
it used to
mm-hmm you know I think so that's my
question do you like a moment where that
yes yes I think libertarianism and it
started probably failing in the 1970s in
a serious way maybe building up in
various ways but and and libertarianism
Libertarian Party in the u.s. started in
the early 70s and it sort of makes sense
because there was sort of more of an
opening and so it was more true than
than it had been before and I would
argue that it is it is much more true in
2018 than it was thirty years thirty
years ago you know the ADI and when the
Iran books were written in the 1950s it
was like it felt like it was crazy
like when I first and because it's like
so bleak so pessimistic I think or so
you know so so busted so broken you know
when I first read them in like the late
80s it it still felt pretty crazy you
know and then the last decade it's it's
in many ways felt you know much more
correct it was you know there's a in an
Atlas Shrugged there's a the trying to
find who you know who is John Galt the
clues eventually take them to the state
where everything has gone haywire is the
state of Michigan mm-hmm and there's
this great company the 20th century
American Motor Company sort of a thinly
disguised General Motors that had just
gone bankrupt and it was because we've
been completely mismanaged along these
sort of socialist kinds of principles
and Detroit was sort of falling apart
someone was farming in the middle of the
city and this was like 1957 was sort of
a crazy thing and then it's it's it's
it's disturbingly more true today yeah
well you're on Brook who used to be the
head of it ar
too-hoo I've had on the show many times
and I do some speaking events with he
always tells me that when he travels
internationally now that it's the
countries that are sort of worse off at
the moment that are just trying to reset
that find those ideas the most
interesting because they're just
desperate for ideas yes so in a way it
almost sounds like you're calling
libertarianism almost a course
correction for when either capitalism or
not necessary capital isn't for when big
government just gets out of control
libertarian can come in libertarianism
can come in and kind of well that's the
unfurl so that's the hope I mean
certainly on a lot of these sort of bad
burke rhotic things don't don't solve
correct that much and it is probably
very hard for there to be incremental
reform from within and that's why
something likes with a libertarian shock
therapy there maybe maybe what you
actually maybe what you actually need
but but you know one way to think about
what what's happened in the u.s. is you
had you had sort of institutions set up
and then over time they sort of ossified
and degraded so you know when nasa was
started in the in the 1950s you had no
great scientists that were driven
motivated and then eventually it became
sort of more and more bureaucratic and
somehow the politics replaced the
science and we can't reset it you know
something like this I think something
like this happens by the way in a lot of
the private sector where you know big
companies become bureaucratic and less
functional but in the private sector you
can have new companies get started and
if big companies are too badly run they
go broke and in the government thing you
know for government to go broke it has
to be incredibly bad and the and the
tricky questions always how do you
course correct before you get there
right so do you have a general
prescription for how government and
private enterprise can work together is
there a general view on when it is right
that seems to be what a lot of people
are talking about right now cuz I do
sense that there's a as I would call it
sort of a classical liberal movement
happening right now or a libertarian
movement and the question always is well
when then is the right moment for
government to do more or well or do less
depending on which way you look at it
I don't know if I have a sort of
formulaic general answer money my my
ideological bias as a libertarian is
that we should have a smaller government
that's less intrusive less regulatory
mostly across the board I don't think I
have to tell you exactly how small it
should be it should just be it should do
less right you know and we don't have to
talk about and we have to privatize
roads or you know all the sort of Christ
you have drivers like don't have set all
the boundaries we know we have there's a
lot of a lot of room to go a big picture
and then I think in terms of the details
there are of course always these ways
that you can try to reform things try to
make things work better recognizing that
you often have in a super entrenched
bureaucracy so you know if you if you
can shift from public schools to charter
schools that's a way to change the
bureaucracy if you could if you could
shift things where you could you could
fire people it shut down agencies that
would probably reform things quite a bit
even though that's that's seemingly a
very hard left yeah so I wanted to hold
Trump a little bit longer but I feel
like this is the right segue because
there's an interesting piece of Trump
that I think a lot of people a lot of
libertarians are happy with when it you
know comes to cutting taxes cutting
regulation which he's done a ton of and
a few other things in that regard and
then on the other hand it seems that
there is a piece of him that's more than
happy to do as many things by his
executive action as they'll allow him to
do and maybe in some cases he would try
to do things that they wouldn't allow
him to do so you supported the guy so
let's just start there when when it was
bubbling up in your head that that you
were gonna support him or at least or
get you gave his campaign money all of
that what kind of internal discussion of
who are you having whether it's up or
were you having it with friends and
colleagues and things like that well um
well that one of the things that that I
would say was is I think a super
important issue for me and I think
should be for libertarians generally is
is foreign policy and I believe that the
US should have a less interventionist
foreign policy I believe that we've
gotten into too many stupid Wars over
the years and that you know that
these questions of if the government can
kill you or and that's sort like that's
maybe one of the most intrusive forms of
government really hard about you know
how often we we do that and and that
there was some there was some need to to
reset that and I think and so if you
from my point of view if you if you got
someone who's not great on a lot of
issues but was libertarian on foreign
policy that would count for a lot and if
you had one who is good on a lot of
other issues but bad on foreign policy
that would actually erode it in a lot of
ways and I think you know the Bush 43
administration who was also sort of
lower tax anti-regulatory but then
because you had the the insane war in
Iraq and you got to have all these
deficits and you do congressional
log-rolling
and so then you end up with No Child
Left Behind you end up with the Medicare
Part D the whole you know all the sort
of crazy expansion of of the welfare
state as part of the log rolling
exercise for for the for the Foreign
Wars and so if we're going to do the
anti Bush 43
I hope actually have a smaller
government may be the sort of art
committee DeeAnn lever removing that is
foreign policy and is for us to be to be
less engaged and I think that that is
you know and it was and this was this
was the place where where Trump broke
the most sharply from Republican
orthodoxy in the primaries you know the
person who served most opposed to was
you know Jeb Bush yeah who was somehow
represented in just a continuation of
the war strategy you know these
devastating questions like you know was
was the Iraq war a bad idea Jeb had
never thought about it and and it was
and he had never thought about it
because you had this Washington DC pro
war foreign policy bubble and it was
Clinton's the bushes you know Obama may
be moderated a little bit but still got
pulled into Syria we sort of messed up
Libya even more than it had been
for and and and and and and and and I
think Trump represented you know a
really big break I gave I gave to did I
spoke at the convention in 2016 and I
also spoken in in the fall at the at the
washing Prescott in both speeches I I
stressed this foreign policy theme so it
was it was that you know should we
should we should the us really be you
know how aggressively should the u.s. be
involved in Syria and risk you know a
confrontation with uh with with Russia
mm-hmm and I think Trump's instincts
continue to be you know much less in
this in the sort of a superpower
confrontation and if you if you look at
where the opposition the to President
Trump comes from the the sort of the
most deranged part of it is from the
neoconservative Republicans because this
is where he's broken the most with
orthodoxy I think that the Russia debate
is a completely insane debate that we
have like this where you know it's and I
think Trump has been consistent for you
know thirty years we should not have a
you know even if Putin is an evil man it
doesn't mean that we should you know be
risking a nuclear war with with Russia
right so that needs to be a position of
the left by the way recently as 2012
when you know when Romney was hawkish on
Russia and Obama said the 80s are
calling yeah and this is like and then
and so it's it's it there's something
about it's just incredibly crazy how
tribal it is well it's so interesting
because that moment in the debate
between Romney and Obama if the left was
being consistent about this they'd be
looking at Obama now and going man you
must have been the worst president of
all time because you misjudge that and
then that led us to our Russian puppet
president or something but you don't see
that side you don't see that sort of
consistency had anyone these days I
suppose yeah it's it's it's it feels
incredibly deranged but but certainly
the intuition is that we shouldn't be
this fixated on you know escalating
eskalene means potentially military
conflicts with with places like Russia
and and to the extent we have that as as
the focus it distracts us from from a
lot of other things mister axis from the
the very real economic competition we
have with China mhm
and which I think is something we should
be taking more seriously and then of
course even more importantly maybe
distracts us from mom from solving some
of the problems at home so I I do think
you know the foreign policy foreign
policy that's maybe the preliminary step
to - getting to then really fixing on
you know solving their own problems does
that show you how how deranged the
conversation has gotten because if you
listen to conventional thinking on this
most of I think Trump's critics will say
look he's saying all these things about
North Korea or he's making all these
threats about Syria or we dropped the
mother of all bombs or all of these
things but you're actually making the
reverse argument I mean they're trying
to argue that he's really the war monger
he's the one that's gonna lead us to
World War three and really your argument
is he's the one doing the reverse of
those things at least yes for now yes I
mean I look I think I think there is we
have a certain type of
military-industrial complex and so there
are parts of this that are sort of
almost on autopilot but but but
certainly I think all of president
Trump's instincts are to you know it's
like you know if we have to rethink NATO
we have to you know rethink you know how
much we should really be committed to
Afghanistan we have to you know we
shouldn't be escalating like crazy with
with Russia and so on you know
yeah the North Korea dictators and
genocidal maniac but we'll talk to him
so I think the instincts are are very
powerfully in the de-escalatory side
what is it about Trump that made you
think this is the guy could do that
because as I was hearing you say that
you could have said well Ron Rand Paul
he's he's doing a pretty good job on
that stuff right he's been talking about
getting out of these wars for a long
time like you could have been like all
right even when I would watch the
debates I'd be like this poor guy he's
on the stage with the wrong group of
people he's making a lot of sense to me
but this is I screwed I support it you
know I did that court Ron Paul Ron Paul
in both 2008 and 2012 I think that you
know I think in some ways a
Rand Paul was sort of making those
arguments well I actually think Trump
made them more powerfully in the
2015-2016 primaries than even even Rand
Paul and invited a critique Rand Paul a
little bit on this uh it it was sort of
he was sort of making this judgment call
that his dad hadn't been able to get
enough votes and so he got to be a
little bit less double tion foreign
policy had to be a little bit more
agreeable and of course he did you know
doing much less well than his dad
because he sort of in a way downplayed
what might have been one of his best
issues and then and then Trump just
articulated far more powerfully so what
is that x-factor thing with Trump
because obviously this was starting to
be like a runaway train and the all the
momentum was there all the media
attention was there it takes us kind of
back to the beginning of when we sat
down the way you described PayPal when
it started really getting into that
growth phase so you must have seen that
too and thought all right the right
ideas are kind of here but really what
I'm seeing is well it's it's well
there's um you're at least talking about
some things you're talking about some of
the important substance of things that
we should be talking about and and you
know part of it again part of that the
negative part is that it's a contrast to
how bad and a lot of the other people
were yeah I mean I I met a number of the
different Republican candidates running
in 2016 small one-on-one meetings and
they're like zombies you know and it was
just you know yeah just are the
ideological talking points we've sort of
not fluid very hard to to get off-script
to say anything and and that somehow
wasn't wasn't quite always called for
and of course you know you know there
was something else about you know
Hillary Clinton that was very much like
this and and I think you know I think
the the revisionist you know sort of
history people like to now say is that
Hillary Clinton was this terrible
candidate and I you know I think I think
she was she was the best candidate the
establishment could put up you know was
just the ideas were wrong they didn't
make sense you know Hillary Clinton
thinks she should run again in 2020 man
and in a way she's right because in from
her point of view I can understand why
she thinks that because she's smarter
than the other Democrats
she has more experience and you know
within the zombie establishment it may
still makes more sense for it to be
Hillary than it you know someone like
Cory Booker camel Harris yeah but the
ideas are just the ideas would just
become you know completely ossified what
does it say about sort of the state of
the West that when things are basically
pretty good not to say they're perfect
but basically pretty good that if
there's always this feeling that the
establishment has to be destroyed or
washed away well well we there's well
that's a big question but III think
there's something that goes back in our
you know we are you know there's
something about Western and Western
civilization that is it is perhaps
unique as sort of like it's it's open
it's it's self referential self-critical
and so and so and and you don't have
this sort of internal self-criticism and
in other societies and other than
cultures and so you know there's always
there's always an argument that you know
ours is an extremely racist sexist
society discriminates in all kinds of
ways and and without challenging that
for now you can also say that ours is a
society that cares a lot about racism
sex and the cares a lot about injustice
--is that the ways things are not
working and so I think and so I think
the establishment you know has not
gotten a free pass in our society for
for a very long time and that's and you
can say that's that's unhealthy and it
makes us weak or divided but but I think
it's it's a it's that's part of the
motor that drives our our civilization
and you know maybe it you know maybe
goes back to you know you know the
Enlightenment or the Renaissance or you
know the greco-roman or judeo-christian
traditions but you know it's uh when
Jesus Christ says that he's the son of
God you know that you can you can
describe that as a metaphysical
religious statement but you can also
describe it as a
little e atheist statement because
Caesar Augustus was the Emperor and
Caesar his sort of adopted father had
been divinized and so Caesar Augustus
also claimed to be the Son of God that's
when Jesus Christ says that he's the son
of God that is a challenge the
establishment that's an act of political
atheism it's the state is not divine the
establishment is not divine and that I
think that's that's just that's that's
just been part of our civilization and
I'd be I'd be much more worried if
people stopped stop stop it stop asking
these questions yeah so for the people
that are watching or listening to this
right now that still have all the
concerns about Trump that you may or may
not have or that you feel maybe are
somewhat deranged in terms of the
conversation you've met the guy
obviously a bunch of times you know
there's that one video when you guys had
that slightly awkward handshake is there
anything well first I guess I have two
parts this one is do you have any
regrets about supporting and we're
speaking at the convention and I want to
talk a little bit more about that in a
minute also but also is there something
that you can impart on us that maybe we
don't know or that's that's not being
told you know just from sitting down
with the guy is is he more stable than
than the way the media would portray it
or something along those lines we
certainly were less he's certainly very
smart and and it sort of is a common
sense intuitive thing and so there's
there's sort of a way that you know he
can x-ray people and can get an
immediate read on on somebody that's
that's incredibly impressive
yeah and so do you think there's a risk
in that also always relying on that
instinct as opposed to only it's it's
well I you know there always are risks
with these things but yes that's you
know it's it's a it's a powerful ability
and and then and then there is a degree
to which it you know he has his ideas
and you know it's sort of he's thought
these things through for himself and
sort of the evidence that you know he's
not as conformist is that is that the
ideas are actually pretty different you
know it's it's you know he's broken with
the Republican orthodoxy on foreign
policy you know
there's um you know rethinking the
immigration question rethinking the free
trade questions and and these are these
are these were like not not mainstream
views at all pretty 2016 yeah and and
there is a way in which you know what I
think has been even more impressive than
I would have expected is is the degree
to which the debate has shifted and so
if we if we take the the debate about
free trade you know the consensus in
2015 would have been free trade is
simply good in all times in all places
and if you don't understand that then
you didn't study econ one and you're you
know you're a low IQ person end of
argument and and at this point you know
it's it's much closer to you know
there's obviously something just very
very wrong with a lot of the trade
arrangements in the world it's like you
know we have we have a we import four
hundred seventy five billion dollars a
year from China we export 100 billion a
year to China and it's completely
unbalanced and and this is actually not
if you we had a genuinely globalizing
world that's not the way it would look
at all a globalizing world the the less
develop arts the world would grow faster
and therefore capital should flow to
those parts and and therefore we should
have a trade surplus with China that we
get extra capital that we then export so
in the right way you're almost making a
globalist argument for him even though
he's always against the globe is a
little different so yeah I would say
that I would say that the incredible
trade imbalances tell us that
something's completely wrong with the
sort of pollyannish globalization story
we're told mm-hmm it's you have Chinese
peasants saving money and it's being
sent up stream into the slower growing
US and the even slower growing Japan and
Western Europe and it's all the money is
flowing it's flowing in the wrong
direction and that tells us some things
you know and you're doing then we can
debate you know what do you do about it
you know do you do you escalate in order
to deescalate do you do you how you know
how do you rethink these things but but
it's it's all it's all
been opened up and I the prediction I
would make is that whoever the
Democratic nominee in 2020 is they will
not they will not disagree with the
Trump on the trade issue they won't
admit the Trump changed their mind
whoo-hoo but this is one of the ways you
win debates is that people come around
to your side and they they still say
they never I know it wasn't because of
you all right was that's how you really
went yeah was that his really clever
move during the the primary still where
he kept saying oh look how unfairly the
DNC is treating Bernie because basically
he was hinting to all of those people
that were so frustrated with the system
when they screw him over guess what I'm
your guy it's not it's not Hillary so it
was a pretty pretty pretty clever little
tip with all these all these things like
this but I think I think it is it is
just these other debates where the
country you know I think you know the
question about NATO is is on the table
now and you know once you put it on the
table you know why should the u.s. be
paying the lion's share when we're
actually mostly defending these other
countries like NATO's on the southern
border defending us from Mexico right
right and you if you listen to the way
the mainstream media focuses it it's
always well Trump wants to blow up NATO
but that's not really what he said he
said he wants other countries to pay
their fair share
those are very very different things yes
I mean they're linked because you might
say you know if you don't you know we're
we might be willing to pull out if you
don't pay your fair share so it's not
mm-hmm it's not like we're never gonna
change but but certainly certainly
people people nobody would disagree that
everyone should pay their fair share
when I talk to even people in Germany
which is like punk may be the most
egregious offender of all nobody
disagrees with on this behind closed
doors mm-hmm so do you have any regret I
don't have any regrets about it you know
I I would say that it it certainly was a
it's been a crazier two years than I
would have thought and and I
underestimated how you know how intense
some of the feelings people have about
politics are but no regrets yeah what do
you make just the general tenor then
right now that we sort of are between a
rock and a hard place where it's like
you've got Trump and he's not gonna
change his tactics and you know I think
I've been very fair to him and that's
why I get a lot of criticism on that
front and then you've got the the
resistance or whatever you want to call
it that seems to be doubling down on a
lot of the bad ideas that got them there
in the first place and that both sides
now are just splitting and splitting and
we're losing what I where I think most
people are which is within some sort of
basically free society libertarian
live-and-let-live thing I think I really
believe that's where most people are but
we seem to be being pulled in in
opposite ways well the way I would I
would frame a little bit differently I
would say we're we're we're moving past
the bush clinton sort of duopoly mm-hmm
and and which was not exactly
libertarian it was putting they're
pretty narrow zone it wasn't very much
debate you know all the smart people
supposedly agreed on everything and it
didn't work all that well at the end of
the day and we had sort of you know one
one fake bubble in our economy after
another and and it and you know it sort
of got us into a lot of things that that
were were not optimal and so so I think
you know for the bush Clinton maybe also
Obama year so those 24 years the debate
I would say was was was was too narrow
and I think within that sort of super
narrow center-to-center left
debate in this country you you're not
going to find the solutions to problems
it's gonna be it's gonna be way outside
of that and and I think you know I think
we will not go back you know we're not
going to go back to Hillary Clinton into
money money we're not going to go back
to Jeb Bush and it's going to be it's
going to be a more wide open debate and
there are the parts of it that I don't
like yeah I know I think you know i
think i think the socialist question is
going to be on the table in ways that it
hasn't been for a long time and and i
think you know I suspect the Democratic
Party is gonna move much further to the
left and that's going to be a debate
we're gonna be having for the next
decade you know I ain't there
I think that's not going to work but
it's it's again it's the clinton the
narrow clinton stuff not going back to
that okay so one more thing on trump for
now when you finally then came out so to
speak and said alright I'm gonna support
Trump just personally do you feel like
it cost you anything just you know
friends family like or did you even care
if that was going to be the case because
a certain amount of people are gonna go
no matter what you just said here about
all the legitimate issues related to
trade and government all that they're
gonna go he's racist so now teals racist
or something along those lines you know
i i'd only it didn't cost me any
friendships and you know and but there
probably were you know there was some
set of people that you know where they
were mad at me that had not been mad at
me before and you know that's
unfortunate I don't I don't um you know
I I didn't think it was that
controversial you know I you know sort
of I sort of like like in one we was one
of the least contrarian and things I've
ever done was like half the country it's
not that contrarian right I've heard you
say that before it's valued felt really
contrarian yeah but but so that's that's
sort of why in a trick if you're doing
something that half the country agrees
with you on that it's kind of weird for
that to be beyond the pale and maybe it
is that's actually hilarious several
drugs with your least contrarian move it
was it was it was in a way the least
contrarian thing I've done and so so it
it it's kind of you know but but there
is something about the politics that's
intense it it's felt zero-sum for a long
time
and and you know it is polarized it's
extreme we don't know what the answers
are and so there are there are ways that
it's been it's been weaponized that are
that are not always not always healthy
so I I you know I don't think we can go
back to the status quo ante
unfortunately fortunately or
unfortunately that's just sort of gone
with the wind we're not going back you
know it's and and it's it's quite
possible we're gonna you know have sort
of you know ever more intense politics
for quite some
time and one of my colleagues coined
this term about a decade ago that you
know it was the John Jim Kramer the
crazy person on CNBC yeah he has this
line where there's always a bull market
somewhere you have to just look for it
you have to know where to find it and
you know and then the bull market my
colleague suggested this was Brown 2008
that was getting started was a bull
market in politics and which is not a
not necessarily place where you want
there to be a bull market but but I
think I think we are in a sort of bull
market in politics and and it it still
has no end in sight and and we're gonna
be looking for options that are further
outside the box and and the debate may
be there may be even more intense in the
years ahead than in his but that's been
it's been before all right I think
that's enough about Trump for now I have
a feeling he'll probably appear again
but let's talk about sense making
because Eric Weinstein who I guess is
the architect of the intellectual dark
web who is the what is his title he is
the managing director of Dale capitals
many hats a man of many hats okay so one
of the ideas that he has discussed many
times in this very studio is that what's
happening right now is that our sense
making our communal sense making in
America is just failing that our ability
to trust the media or CNN or New York
Times or the rest of it has failed to
the point that this intellectual dark
web this crew of about 20 or so people
are the last bastion of our ability to
just make sense of things or at least
try to be sensitive so I have a couple
questions on this but first Eric works
for you you guys have major
disagreements he was a bernie guy you
obviously supported Trump I'm sure he's
been on these shows and talked about
probably policies that you don't agree
with and things like that yet you let
this guy do whatever he wants I think
that's a great credit to you but why why
do you do it I mean why do you let this
guy run around and and do whatever he
wants to do even when it's in conflict
with what you believe I don't think most
people would do that well I'm I'm
interested in idea as always and I think
that I don't think all the
is our our just the conventional ideas I
think there are I think that I think we
need to find new ideas new ways of
approaching the world thinking about it
and and Eric is certainly you know
absolutely first great heterodox thinker
and and you know I don't think you know
I think all of our politics are somewhat
eclectic and somewhat complex and you
know and you know Eric's more on the
left I'm more on the right but but we
both interested in ideas we're
interested in figuring out how to make
sense of our world and and that unites
us and and and it's always surprising
how that's a pretty unusual place to be
there yes it's it's much of it's not
about ideas it's as we said earlier it's
about power or fashion or or something
like that but but most guys in your
position wouldn't be allowing one of
their their top people to be out there
often taking positions that are against
them that there's something about you
that's allowing you to do that right you
know I I know I know you don't want to
sit here and pat yourself I think it's
an important piece of something I think
I'm not sure I'm right about this but
let me be a little bit more modest
honest but um I think most most of my
peers in Silicon Valley think that the
ideas are are more set we sort of know
all the right answers it's inefficient
it's a waste of time to be exploring
outside of that and and so the sort of
the substantive question you have to ask
is are the ideas right or you know
should we have more exploration so it's
like you know you take the take the
climate change debate mm-hmm there's
there's a view that you know we know
it's happening or we go to yeah we know
that it's a runaway problem and and and
if we we can't we can't even pause
mm-hmm and think about it because we
know all these things we have to just
focus all our energy on on solving them
and so if those things are true then
that might be reasonable if they're if
they're not entirely true like maybe you
know maybe maybe climate change is maybe
it's more methane than carbon dioxide in
which case may be eating steak is worse
than driving a car
it's maybe maybe climate change the
problem it's a little different from the
way we think it is and so if these
things are not true then we need to have
much more of a debate and so the the
kind of question that's very hard that
you have to have make some judgment on
us do we more or less have the truth
about everything or don't we yeah and my
views that we're like really far off and
I think a lot of my peers think you know
you were kind of at the end of history
we've sort of figured everything out
there's we don't want to be long ideas
we don't want to be you know interesting
weird ideas are just wrong and they're
just a waste of time
and that's that's sort of their their
bias mine's the opposite yeah do you
think that this set of people and I
think I would include you in that and in
a broader sense I mean now you're
sitting here and doing this do you think
we have a chance of resetting some of
this stuff I mean I think that just if
you look in the last week I mean olan
going on Rogen you sitting down here
again without patting myself on the back
for a moment like I view that as like a
landscape change of the way people that
are our influencers our visionaries are
reacting well in media I think yeah look
I think look I think boxes are too
narrow you know it's like what one it's
like we you know it's like the baby
boomer since 1968
they've been relitigate in 1968 for 50
years we've had like the same fights
they're getting kind of old but it's
been then Groundhog Day for 50 years and
um and and maybe there's something past
Groundhog Day and that's that's the bias
you have otherwise I have right and and
I think part of it is it's not just
talking about talking about ideas it's
you know it's bringing forth some
specific ideas these are things that are
different that are changing that are you
know that where the world may look very
different in the future from where it
looks in the present but I I think we're
not at the end of history we're not at a
time where ideas don't matter or where
people can't do things
I think the future will be very
different from the present maybe it's
gonna be better maybe it's gonna be
worse it's up to us and and so I'm I'm
super-long having a very broad
conversation about things yeah I'm glad
that you brought up the baby boomers for
a moment cuz it does seem like that
partly what's happening here is that
they're at their last
grasps of controlling things and in an
odd way gen-x my generation got which I
think you're probably at the right
around the little bit ahead of me on Gen
X that we sort of got lost and then we
it's like almost like we handed
everything off to the Millennials but we
didn't give them any of the tools to be
able they were too young and didn't have
the tools or the or the financial
instruments to be able to make any
change does that does that mean well
there are a lot of strange generational
dynamics one could one could talk about
I've been very struck in recent months
in thinking about this how there is
something very odd in terms of what
happened to Gen X which is people born
say 1965 to 1980 it was the birth years
a boomers were sort of 46 to 64 yeah and
and somehow you know the Boomers
dominated things like crazy and and
there was we were so like in the shadow
of these people on and then all sorts of
different in all sorts of different
contexts and it was it was Gen X was
probably first time that you had a
generation that was smaller in numbers
and the one that came before us you know
it's sort of coincided with an era of
slower growth slower progress so there
were fewer opportunities to rise you
know baby boomers held onto their
positions and in some ways you know it
was like when I when I started working
in a law firm in Manhattan in the early
90s I mean I was I wasn't thinking about
consciously this way but it was the baby
boomer partners they just become partner
and they were sort of pulling the ladder
up behind them and it was gonna be much
harder for people my generation our
generation to to do the same things to
go down the track in the same in the
same way and so there is something you
know there's something very weird about
how how Gen X has gotten you know it has
been sort of sidelined by the Boomers
for so long
yeah and then the the rap on us is
always that we're you know we're too too
young or too old right and so we were
you know in the 90s when Gen X was
starting the tech companies we were seen
as too young and who needed adult
supervision we needed the baby boomers
to run the companies and that's an
almost every Gen X
of founder and some exceptions but I'm
over whelming Lee the boomers took over
the company's there was a version this
with Yahoo and eBay Netscape even Google
which was the biggest of the Gen X
companies we got a 10-year period where
Eric Schmidt the baby boomer took over
took over Google whereas you know the
Boomer companies Apple Microsoft Amazon
Microsoft and Amazon were just saying
people got to run the whole time mm-hmm
and then you know a little bit more
chaotic Facebook millennial company they
got to run it Gen X not so much do you
think I think I think what could and and
tech is like meritocratic it's not
supposed to be about right culture and
voting and stuff like this and then I
think I think on a pop on a political
level it's striking how underrepresented
we are you know
2020 should be should be a prime year
for a Gen X presidential candidate on
the Democratic side so Warren between
1965 and 1980
and I challenge you to name me a single
plausible Gen X Democrat I don't pick a
loser like Cory Booker right I mean
that's the thing well I think there's
several reasons for that on the
Democratic side but god it's somehow the
Boomers they're more of them and so they
they they look like it's it's truth and
numbers and it's the baby boomer bubble
in a way has always been that the
numbers make it right that if you have a
lot of people it's true and that's kind
of what worked and so you know it the
boomers were this unusually big
generation and it was just about them it
just about getting consensus and then
you could overwhelm things and that's
that's what you had to do and I think
that's that sort of coming to an end
slowly
I wonder do you think there's also just
a flat-out technological component to
this that we in Gen X we're the last
generation that grew up without all of
this tech so I don't know what the exact
connection is but I remember being in
college I think my freshman year I
remember some kid down the hallway
screaming on the internet and I went
into his room and I've told the story
couple times I went
to his room and it said Yankees three
Royals one and it had two pictures at
Lola's and I swear on my life I remember
thinking this is the stupidest thing
I've ever seen like we did not grow up
with the phones in our pockets we didn't
grow up connected all of those things so
it almost seems to me there's some
connection to that where then the
Millennials came in they were so
connected to all of this then the media
because the media wants cliques and
everything paid so much attention to
them that that may be pushed out Gen X a
little bit more do you think there's I'm
just I'm just doing this cultural
history it's always many variables yeah
super overdetermined I I do think
there's there's um there's something
about the Millennial vibe that feels
more conformist ya and Gen X feels less
conformist and and so and so one of the
you know good and bad things about being
overly connected overly technologically
connected is you know you get to get to
know the score right away you get the
answer right away you know you're
supposed to be scared of climate change
right away and that's good if it's true
ah that's bad if it's a shortcut
and so our generation because hey was
the last one where that didn't take
shortcuts and most the time you the
boomers learned to take shortcuts we you
know we didn't take as many shortcut I
like that Millennials know to take all
the shortcuts and it's a good idea to
take shortcuts in a world where nobody
takes shortcuts in a world where
everybody takes shortcuts you know you
have to actually figure out maybe the
shortcut isn't gonna work and and you're
actually better off figuring out the
other thing yeah so one way to frame is
to be in the boomer era the boomers who
figured out how to take shortcuts so the
shortcut in politics is I'm not gonna
figure out what I think about the issues
I mean just go look at the polls mhm and
the pollster is the one who's really
running for president listening to the
pollster and that was that was an
effective boomer technique for many
years that you just look at the polls
and if you were you had a better
pollster you could more quickly get to
where the puck was going where the crowd
was going and you didn't need to think
in
waste time thinking about stuff and so
in a world where very few people were
doing it that could be a very good
strategy by the time you get to that
something like the Millennials where
everyone's been trained to do shortcuts
that it somehow it doesn't quite work it
vaguely maps onto the tracking because
you can think of tracking and school
tracking professionally is a way that
it's like a shortcut to a successful
career and so the baby boomers who
stayed on track did quite well so we
didn't you know tune in and drop out and
the late 60s and just went to law school
and you being a partner in a law firm
that it kind of tracks worked mm-hmm by
the time we get to the Millennials they
know all the tracks you're supposed to
do tracks work less well when everybody
knows them everyone's doing the same
thing so it has there's sort of there
are these similarities between the
Millennials and the Boomers but the
lesson that they're they're the really
different in practice and it's working
really differently so the things that
would have worked perfectly for you as a
Boomer are deadly if you're a millennial
yeah so okay so hearing that and knowing
that our sense making is breaking down
and our ability even our ability to just
get away from all this what you said
before about you know paying that much
attention to politics and all that
everyone asks the whole IDW crew
constantly well what are you guys gonna
do and you just said something about you
know we shouldn't just talk about these
things we gotta do things do you see
either a technological answer here or a
business answer here or something and I
we've talked about this a little bit
privately before and it's been kind of
bouncing around but like everyone wants
some answers to what's going on here
with the media and and everything else
and and the pipes you know that Google
owns all the pipes and all of that yeah
and I think a lot of people as a default
position is well to old fix it was it's
like there's only a couple people that
actually could well it's it's um I don't
I don't actually quite know what one
does to to fix the media industry I I
would say the on the thing that I'm
always super fixated on is the business
model questions my zero to one book the
so the main motif is always on the
shouldn't compete you should try to have
a monopoly should try to do something
that you do so well that you have no
competition and you know there are good
and bad things about monopoly but from
the inside you generally want to have a
monopoly it gets a little bit bad if you
become too fat and lazy and and if you
then ever have competition you're really
in trouble
and you know in a way the the business
history I would tell of the the
mainstream media is that they used to
have great monopolies the newspapers had
local content monopolies and they got
local monopolies and advertisers because
the only way could advertise was through
the classified section a newspaper or
news magazines or you know they're all
these sort of all these sort of media
monopolies and what technology what the
Internet has done is it's it's it's
opened things up in ways that are good
for information for for learning things
but it's very bad for their business
models and and I think this is something
they they never really understood
mmm-hmm and so if you were you know if
you were at the Washington Post in the
1990s you know if you sort of imagine
what the holiday party would have been
like um you know the the owner of the
post would have said something like you
know you know we're all you're all
getting paid you know we're doing great
business is doing great we have all
these talented people that are writing
great stories and so the narrative would
be that it was a great business because
of the great work the people they were
doing and the true story was something
like know you're working for a utility
company and doesn't matter what you do
because we'll we're gonna make these
monopoly profits year after year after
year and then when the monopoly story
started to break the story was not the
monopolies going away because they can't
talk about that right right but the
story was rather we don't we don't know
anything about the internet or something
like that right and so I think I think
the the challenge that a lot of the
media old media businesses have haven't
even been described correctly mmm-hmm
and then you know and then it's but then
it is
it's sort of it sort of plays out and
you know in you know it and and and you
have to figure out some new ways to get
distribution channels new ways to
monetize and you know there are there I
think there will be models for doing
that but that's the that's the question
how to do it how do you you know you
can't go back to the old monopolies
though yeah we need some answers all
right let's let's shift a little bit to
some of your some of your history
because I think a lot of people or a
certain set of people probably only know
you through the the Gawker
prism and every time I read anything
about Gawker or what happened with you
or Hulk Hogan it always seems so
distorted the way they presented which
is probably very obvious to you but to
me it was like you weren't people
because people will say well he'll hates
the media he sued a publication he
obviously hates the media and it's like
actually you were defending the right to
privacy which is something that the
media should be doing in and of itself
what made you want to get involved in
this you had your own history with
Gawker obviously before Hogan yes and
all that yeah it is you know there are
all these elements the story that are of
course you know sort of a little bit
larger than life where you have sort of
a sociopathic Manhattan media company
and I think that's a to kind of our
interim code name for Gawker was the MBT
oh the manhattan-based terrorist
organization there you go well you've
liken them to al-qaeda before and then
yeah it was it was some I was a crazy
story no nine where they I'm just
completely distorted things I was
speaking to report at the San Jose
Mercury News and I was like what do you
think of them I said oh that they'll
Qaeda Silicon Valley yeah okay say that
yes you can and because of course you
get on but but the the the and so I
think they were sort of this and it was
in some ways you're all sorts of things
you can say about they were kind of
crazy and it was super destructive they
went mostly they didn't go after people
like myself they went after people who
were relatively powerless you know
often just average people not public
figures in any sense of the word
you know Hogan was sort of an in-between
person he'd been like a very
high-profile celebrity but was
definitely it was definitely beating up
on a weaker person in a in the context
in which they they did it and so it had
a it had this sort of heroic underdog
fighting this the sort of hate factory
yeah hate factory machine back at the
right way to describe get targeted at at
various at various people you know you
know we have a First Amendment and I
believe in I believe in freedom of
speech you know and you have of course
always you know the the Hogan trial the
you know the jury trial it's a jury
trial
you can always argue the law we can
argue the facts so the the the Gawker
side argued the law which is you know
we're there's a First Amendment and it's
sacred and we're journalists we get to
do whatever we want that's sort of that
was roughly their argument the the Hogan
side of it was you published a sex tape
that was secretly taken in the privacy
of a bedroom and those are the facts
that has nothing to do with the First
Amendment
mhm it might have something to with the
Fourth Amendment which is against
unreasonable search and seizure huh not
just by government but also by you know
private people obviously and and and and
so you know and so yeah is there a comp
can there be a conflict between freedom
of speech and and right to privacy
probably are cases where in theory there
can be conflict but this was one where
it was simply a violation of privacy and
I would say it wasn't speech at all and
then and then you know yeah sir all
sorts of like super you know egregious
facts that came out in trial you know
one of the one of the reporters uh the
editors had posted the sex tape you know
he he had a deposition with with the
with the it was a one day long
deposition a few years before the trial
and and it was you know you got a lunch
break and come back after lunch
AJ dole area came back
reeking of marijuana which not not
against it but I wouldn't do on your
show I didn't little of a legal
deposition either yeah and then you know
the lawyer in our site asked a Steller's
is there any sex tape you wouldn't
publish well I guess it involved a child
it was like what age child a
four-year-old uh-huh and so when you
show that to the jury that's that's
pretty devastating and so it it was one
of these things where you know we I
thought that if if mister if Terry
Bollea al Kobe ever had his day in court
it was going to be a runaway effect
mm-hmm he was gonna be completely run
away and and that's that's that's an
effect what happened you know the last
day of the trial
Charles harder he thought he thought the
largest amount of money he could ask for
with a straight face was 100 million
dollars and then you know after seven
hours the jury comes back with 115 and
so it was just it was just it was just a
runaway thing and it was you know maybe
it was you can argue that was too much
for this one person but in some ways it
was it was you know it was a million
post they they published over the years
that were that was what was really at
stake right well I think a lot of people
the people that that liked you and
defend you on this will say well this
was a defense actually a free speech it
was a defense of just the the media
coming after it everybody finding out
anything you've ever done finding out
any access to any picture you've ever
sent or any of that and we see the way
this is this is sort of infecting
everything in society this is a not that
simple argument to make but the the way
I would argue is I think I think we need
to have vigorous debate we need to have
people with heterodox views be able to
articulate things and and you can
silence people by not letting them speak
but you can also silence them by if you
say something that's even slightly out
of line we are going to send the hate
mob a tray and we're gonna make up
stories about you and and and personally
destroy you and in a way that was the
logic of the
of the hate factory of the scapegoating
machine that was Gawker it you know in
in some ways the victims were picked at
random and in some ways they were not at
random in some ways they were the non
conformists they were the people with
with views that were were sort of
heterodox i suspect that's one of the
reasons they they targeted me and again
i was not targeted more than some other
people hurt even more than i was but
yeah but it was he was it was very often
people who said things that were just a
little bit outside the zone and then
they were destroyed and the lesson was
was one of silencing yeah so we should
talk a little bit about them targeting
you so so they may in effect they outed
you
right I mean is that were they
officially the ones that that outed you
you know I don't I think even that
history can be sort of contested sites I
mean I know you were out privately and
so I think hard to say I think was it
was sort of it it was in a somewhat in
between zone they they targeted me
repeatedly over years it was it was that
it was it was various other articles on
the and it was of course if we talk
about outing it's it's never it's never
a simply factual thing mm-hmm
it's never a Peter or David or gay FYI
it is it's more like Peter teal is gay
and we have no idea why didn't want us
to talk about it right and maybe it's
because maybe it's because his parents
don't know and they'd be embarrassed or
maybe it's because he's trying to get
money out of Saudi Arabia and and we
don't really we don't really know why
yeah and so so outing is always the way
it worked I think it happens actually
much less but the way it worked
always involved a description of
someone's sexual orientation and a
description of how psychologically
messed up they were right because they
didn't want you to write the article and
the way I think our society has
progressed is that the word we have for
outing today is something like bullying
mm-hmm and the question is shifted from
the psychology of the person being
written about
to the psychology of the writer and the
question is why would you why would you
do something as nasty as this and so
there was that's a pretty powerful but
it's been a very big cultural chef yeah
so in 2007 when they when they when they
went after me outing was still
acceptable mm-hmm
in 2015 they went after the CFO of Conde
Nast and you know yet again sort of who
knows the story was even true right but
but the response was well it's an
incredibly vicious thing why are your
reporters so vicious why are they so
hateful what's wrong with you to be and
it was sort of like linked to bullying
high school bullying all these all these
kinds of phenomena so so we've so I
think I think I think things you know I
think we have actually progressed you
know transparency doesn't always mean
that you make things better it's it's
sometimes it's just it's just Nick you
know it's a just an excuse for for
attacking people do you think that in
your case that it was also directly
linked to your politics because if you
had been the exact same person you are
with the exact same resume and it
created the exact same companies but you
had been a lefty you had been playing
ball the way that they want you to play
ball that yeah why would they try to
harm you I mean in effect they were
trying to harm you one way or another I
think that's why they they do these
things that's why the the label bully is
applicable here that to me it's like
well he's the libertarian he's some
scary anti-government guy so how can we
get him let's out him do you think
that's a fairest maid you know it's it's
probably a factor it's hard to you know
I think I think on some level we were
just trying to get page close just
something I mean I you know it's it's um
we're still I think that you're being
too charitable to them in a way because
you're giving them an ideological motive
and you're saying okay they were these
principled left-wing people who went
after the bad right-wing power structure
that is a printable baya yeah and I
think they weren't even they were more
nihilistic than liberal or left-wing and
and you know you could you could dress
up the nihilism we're gonna blow
somebody up
we're gonna do some crazy attack on some
random person and we're gonna try to
give it some thin ideological gloss but
I think it was just it was just you know
it was it was like it was run as like
this crazy sweatshop where you know the
the the people were paid very little and
they were paid based on how many clicks
they got and so you had to come up with
crazy sensational headlines and then
stories that you know sometimes had a
relationship with the truth and
sometimes didn't yeah and that has
really permeated the internet altogether
now I mean if I look every week you know
I'm on tour with Jordan Peterson it's
like every morning I wake up and it's
like somebody writes something awful
about him that I know is not the truth
and it's like they have every interest
in doing it because he will defend
himself thus driving clicks although I
know I will still say that I think
Gawker was in some ways a singularly
sociopathic phony and and it is true
that there's a lot of stuff like what
you you characterize I don't think I
think people discounted more it has less
impact I think you know in its heyday
Gawker had impact because they were they
were sociopathic they were bullying and
people didn't see it yet and that's
that's the devastating kind you know if
you're if you try to bully someone
everybody says right away you're a bully
you might still be a bully but not as
not you're not gonna be that effective
right if you're bullying people say oh
this is just the Internet this is tech
this is the future you're gonna have
cart wash and so Gawker had cart launch
for many years to destroy people in a
way that I think has gotten much less
effective I mean still happens they're
still you know you can have the hate mob
form on Twitter or they're sort of still
versions of this but it's it it's it's
much less generative all right so let's
let's talk about sexuality for a little
bit because this isn't something that
you talk about that often we've talked
about it privately a little bit well you
first off you're married congratulations
you got married and though in the last
year how much of your sort of contrarian
view of the world just the way you see
things differently do you think is
linked to being gay because before just
the last couple
where I think being gay has been so
attached to leftism gay used to mean fun
or different or politically incorrect
and making edgy jokes and being it
subversive clubs or all of these other
things whatever it was and gays were
really about the individual that was the
whole point you now are sort of as I
said it's kind of the ultimate
contrarian and I wonder is there a link
between that and sexuality do you think
I wouldn't I wouldn't want to exaggerate
and he's any such link um and I think
you know IIIi think of myself as like
there's I'm always bad at autobiography
so I'll start that qualifier but I
always think of myself as somehow I was
both a total insider and a total
outsider so I was like straight-a
student you know on on the elite
university elite law school elite law
firm track you know it's a bit of a nerd
I was you know I was you know I was born
in Germany sort of immigrant to the US
you know the gay thing so all these so
all these ways that I was talking about
both an outsider and insider and
probably there's some way yeah some way
all this stuff you know summed up to to
make me less less prone to just
believing in the received wisdom mm-hmm
but I you know I would I would I would
certainly not want to say anything
remotely like that that gay people have
a privileged access to the truth or
anything like that that's that that
seems kind of crazy okay so a couple
years ago you go to the Republican
National Convention and you talked about
being gay which had always been an
athame over there what was the exact
line that you had said well it was a I'm
proud to be gay I'm proud to be a
Republican most of all I'm proud to be
an American and and so it was it was it
was and so I think it functioned in both
a way that you know every American has
an identity it's it's not something we
should ignore or totally diminish
and we should not make it all-important
and we start trying to steer a certain
you know middle course on on on identity
politics sir where you know it's I think
it's very easy to go too far in one one
direction or another you can say that
you know that all identity is fake it
doesn't matter it's all made up and
that's I think that's that's wrong I
think there's an african-american
experience there's a female experience
there's a gay experience and they are
they're different and then and then of
course there's you know an equally bad
mistake of making it all important where
you know that's all there is that's what
defines you and then it ends up becoming
more of a straitjacket so you know the
or the gate the gay metaphor that I've
used is that you know you know you can
be in the closet you can be in the
ghetto and there those are they're
mutually exclusive but I hope they're
not exhaustive there's something in
between right because those two are
pretty something that's neither neither
of those two yeah so when you step out
in the closet I don't wanna be in the
ghetto yeah so when you said that line
and then got bad ovation first off were
you we're nervous to say that line cuz
that that's a little small feet just to
have it in the speech and ready to go
here is later nervous to speak you know
it's just you know it's like speaking to
15,000 people or it's kind of a strange
you know super adrenaline type
experience yeah but that particular line
I mean when you got the applause on that
there must have been some part of you
that was like it worked or or or
something has changed or yeah something
that's alright you know I again I I
don't think I don't think the
Republicans are that anti-gay they don't
think of that anti and I mean I think
maybe that maybe they were in the past
but but but it was it was clear that
this was not the issue this was not the
hill they wanted to die on in 2016 it so
somebody had to say it
yeah so unless I did you know it felt a
little bit risky but I don't even want
to exaggerate that yeah I think I think
it would have been a very crazy thing to
say 20 years earlier yeah all right
let's shift to some new ideas how about
how do you feel about that so let's do
some new idea
so seasteading is one of the things that
you've been interested in for years this
idea that we're gonna basically create
in effect states that are gonna be on
platforms in the sea that I think are
sort of going to be libertarian utopia
is or at least that would be the the
general idea seems like it had a lot of
momentum behind it for a while then kind
of went away I think there's some
renewed interest in it now what got you
interested in this and well where is it
at now it it was a Milton Friedman it
sort of knew Milton Friedman a little
bit his grandson patrie Friedman mm-hmm
sort of got in touch with and and he was
super he sort of spearheaded this
seasteading idea probably about a decade
ago now and it was sort of a creative
different interesting idea you know I
gave it a small amount of funding it
wasn't one of the things I did that much
with but it it somehow hit an incredible
nerve mm-hmm and so and I think it's and
it hits such a nerve because in this
idea of starting a new country or doing
something new it reminds people that if
we had to design a country from scratch
from design the state of California from
scratch it would be so different and you
know there's all these sort of super
corrupt governance institutions we'd
clean out and we'd you know and and so
it's a you know I'm not sure I've called
utopian but it's a it's a thought
experiment that that gets that energizes
people and gets them to think about
things I spoke at this free market
University in Guatemala years ago and
they told me that they had free speech
on everything but the one thing that you
weren't allowed to speak about where
things like see studying or scar
countries reason you won a lot to speak
about them was that if you started
people don't want to talk about anything
else right and it's because it's because
it's it's always such a such a powerful
hook and you know there are there
questions about whether it will be
allowed so you have to sort of get
probably some some local permission
there's a question on how
technologically feasible it is there's
sort of a pilot program that they're
working with French Polynesia
and starting it's still somewhere in the
you know in the intermediate stage but
yeah you can prop see if you can get um
if you can get political autonomy the
assumptions you would do things are very
different
I do medical tourism you might - you
know there might be all sorts of
offshore banking you could do there all
kinds of things
that one might be able to do differently
and and the you know the link to the
link to - to technology that you know I
mean I think he said you know you've let
a lot of these different microstates
bloom and you'd sort of see what would
come out of the the specific
technological scientific technological
thing that I think could come out of
some new political arrangements at some
point it's always this question whether
we could get new medicines new drugs you
know could you have something where you
know you use psilocybin or MDMA as a
antidepressant drug mm-hmm or can you
get can you get new on can you get on
new medical treatments through where you
sort of break the FD a monopoly on on
medicine worldwide so basically you
would see all of these different units
sort of having different rules that they
live by kind of as an experiment to see
what would work is that that's that's
one level but then the specific thing
that I would so you know that's that's
the general abstract hold the Pacific
thing that I I would hope would come out
of it would be more scientific and
technological progress that's too
heavily regulated by the heavy hand of
our existing state and that there are
all these things we can't do so there's
it all sorts of things of governance it
might be better you might have you know
a different penal system or you know
have you know millions of people who are
incarcerated there all sorts of things
one might do very differently the the
specific one that I that I'm probably
most attract who is this is this
question of whether we can do new
biomedical things yeah so we could do
three hours just on this but it's only
one more question on this which is how
do you decide who gets in on this how do
you decide who can who can live there
who can be part of this I mean there's
this purely a financial move if you've
got enough money you're good to go
or do you are you trying to build a
society and and picking all sorts of
other people and and all of those things
well you get you get you have to make
all these decisions get to make these
decisions make these decisions and
that's and that's but I think that's
that's always you know that's always
sort of one of the foundational
decisions in the society who who's part
of it how do we define it and and you
know it's it can be unfair and
oppressive if if you have just one
society and if you're not in it you're
nowhere mm-hmm but if you have if you
have many of these places that's that's
very different
yeah and that's oh the pushback on this
is then that that somehow this means you
don't like America or something like
that which is I know but I I certainly
think that if we have competition
governance we we could we would do a lot
better yeah all right so let's let's
move so flying cars Elan is against them
now he's building an underground tunnel
in this very city where he out on the
flying cars these days plus we had the
we had that was a tag line we had on our
on our venture capital website you know
they um they promised us flying cars and
all we got was 140 characters sort of a
we've got 280 now we got up to 280 and
and so it was it was it was uh it was
more a commentary on on technology that
we were we were promised these massive
breakthroughs that would transform the
way the world works and then that we got
sort of incremental communication
technologies but not not world
transforming and so I do think flying
cars would be you know would be a good
thing I know I think eelain's objection
was they were too too noisy and then of
course the questions can you design them
so they're not so noisy so there's
always and so what are what are the
actual limits on on the technology but
the but they're the sort of iconic for
can we have a Jetsons future and we have
a future where things look really
different and the striking thing is that
we live in a world that doesn't look
that different from the 1980s again the
you know we're looking at screens
you know we're distracted by our iPhones
all the time but the
iPhones that distract us from our
environment also distract us from the
way in which our environment
strangely hasn't changed we're running
you know maybe riding on a
hundred-year-old subway in New York City
who or you know the zoning laws mean
that the cities like San Francisco look
like they haven't changed in 50 years no
not a technologically advanced San
Francisco is getting so expensive you
had to leave but being that's not the
size reason but but but but it basically
so it's sort of like can we can we have
more technological progress than we have
and you know it's it's a the the the
sort of iconic image I always have this
you have the two Back to the Future
movies the first one they went from 85
to 1955 and things have changed a lot
from 1955 to 1985 the second one they
went from 1985 to what they thought 2015
would be like and you're gonna have like
I mean all is gonna be like this crazy
different world and I think the reality
is the world of 2015 looks you know much
less different right in the world of
1985 than 85 was from 55 I'm still
waiting for that hoverboard what
happened to the hover but all these
kinds of things yes and so it's and so
there is sort of this this this and I
think that you know one of the one of
the ways our society works one of the
ways liberal democracy or representative
government works is that you have a
scientific technological progress going
on the background you have growth the
pie is growing
if the pie grows we can find creative
ways to to chip the pieces so that
everybody gets more when the pie stops
growing when there is no progress then
you end up with this polarized world
with these zero-sum politics you know
for every winner there's a loser
anyone who succeeds is suspected of
being part of some kind of a racket or
something and and so I think I I think
there is actually you know a pretty uh
there's a link a pretty deep link
between this the question of scientific
and technological progress and the
health of our sort of representative
democracy yeah so I that's a good segue
to a
because we've talked about this a little
bit and you told me something once that
I I'm actually not sure if you've said
publicly but I think it's pretty on
point that basically if you're an
authoritarian you should be for AI and
libertarians are sort of against they I
am I am I getting that roughly correct I
think it was on Bitcoin so yes if crypto
is libertarian then AI is communist so
everyone thinks of crypto is libertarian
because you have all these ideas about
decentralizing money and things like
this nobody says AI is communist and
that's because we're sort of more
conscious of people with different views
like libertarian and we're less
conscious of people with collectivist
views because that's sort of the that's
more the zeitgeist right but but yes I
think AI you know and the the crypto
versus AI dichotomy goes to the sort of
question about what's the future of the
computer age going to look like and and
is it going to be more centralized or
more decentralized we had we got you
think about the history we've had these
very different pictures so you know in
the late 60s the early Star Trek
episodes you had maybe it was one planet
they got to where there was one big
computer that ran the whole planet had
been running it for 8,000 years and the
you know people didn't have any thoughts
they were all sort of docile kind of
happy nothing ever happened and that was
what people thought the future would be
in the late sixties when we centralized
big computers the late 90s it was going
to be crypto it was going to be
decentralized the internet was going to
you know split up all these sort of
structures if you know that was like
1998 let's say so let's see 68 was
centralized 98 was decentralized 20 18
in some ways the pendulum has swung back
to centralized this big governments big
databases that can monitor and survey
people and know more about you than you
know about yourself or think things like
that sort of creepy Big Brother type
thing mm-hmm I think I think since the
pendulum has swung back and forth so
much over the last 50 years there's no
reason that that's the future and it's
actually a choice do we want it to be
centralized do we want it to be
decentralized and what I think again AI
can mean many different things but if it
means that you have law
databases that are controlled by let's
say a large government that can monitor
people more effectively you know it's
something that could make communism
maybe more effective certainly more
scary more totalitarian than it ever was
in the in the 20th century and on the
and I do think and it's not a
coincidence along these lines that the
Chinese Communist Party hates crypto and
the AI and again you know they I mean
something a little bit different what it
means in a Silicon Valley context where
in Silicon Valley I often just means you
know a a super smart computer that will
leave all the humans behind in China it
means a a really smart computer that
helps a few humans control the rust yeah
so it almost seems like we're gonna
splinter off into two versions of this
where we'll have these two tracks
that'll be side by side half the people
are really going to be into this sort of
centralized idea of things and the ease
that AI will allow you to get products
or whatever else it is and then you'll
have this other group of people who
maybe who are into all the crypto
currencies and all that who are just
sort of I suppose operating outside of
the system or something it's you know I
I think it's um it's possible these
things can be overlapping but it's also
possible can go much more one way or the
other and that it can be ultimately that
the future can be more decentralized or
more centralized to give more capitalist
more communist more libertarian more
totalitarian so so I think it can go and
you know a lot of different ways and
it's an input this is why these debates
are important because it's you know up
to us to decide you know which
technologies do we push and which ones
you know are we are we maybe you know
gonna be a little bit more careful and I
don't think you should outlaw AI or
regulate it but uh but I think that that
that certainly are other technologies
that I would like to do better so I know
you're not in the well what are some of
those technology well you know something
like the contrasting example yeah so I
know that a huge percentage of my
audience just cuz they know of all the
craziness I've been through with D
monetization and I'm always complaining
about the algorithm in our video
is not going to feeds and all of these
things and that we've just sort of we
just don't know what's going on you know
and you know my feelings on this about I
don't want the government telling these
companies what to do but I would like a
little more transparency out of it out
of the government I'd like to know
what's kind of going on with the
algorithms and things like that is there
any way we could know more about these
algorithms and things that are giving us
all this information or is that just
there's reasons why we can't know all of
that I'm not even sure if I frame that
question correctly yeah look I always
have to be careful here since I'm on the
face yeah Gordon and I I I certainly
think that in my judgment you know
Facebook has been giving a bit more of a
bum rap than it deserves on on many of
these scores but but I would say that
that I think there is that this this
question is going to continue it's it's
you know does Silicon Valley
discriminating against certain voices is
it are the algorithms in fact neutral or
are they coded to discriminate against
conservative libertarian voices that are
out a little bit outside the mainstream
and I think Silicon Valley is making a
mistake if it thinks that that question
can be sort of swept under the rug and
is going to go away I think I think the
question is going to be asked with with
you know more intensity in the years
ahead and I think people are they're
gonna have to answer it yeah all right
so two more for yeah did you ever think
if 20 years ago someone would have said
to you you know teal in 2018 you're
gonna leave Silicon Valley and not only
you're gonna leave Silicon Valley
you're gonna go to LA for freedom you
know you're gonna go to LA to escape to
find some free thinkers now there's
something interesting happening in LA
right now and it goes to something that
you referenced earlier politics and
media are sort of becoming one thing and
there is suddenly this new home here of
kind of free thinkers that are
interested in politics and all that but
the fact that you ended up here of all
places where this is thought of as
Hollywood and the liberal left the elite
and all that stuff does that seem crazy
to you that of all places you're going
to end up
here now I know the way I don't know
would have predicted it 20 years ago
certain yeah I think I think there's
have a lot of different reasons when
chooses to live in place I like bigger
cities is something there's sort of a
lot a lot of things you can do in big
cities you can't do in it's smaller
places one of the one of the things that
however is a very different feel between
Los Angeles and Silicon Valley is that
Los Angeles is it is a weirdly it is the
big city that is weirdly decentralized
and you know it doesn't have a center
you know people always complain about
how about the traffic is but one of the
virtues of it is it's somehow it isn't
it isn't like this this intense manic
bubble like Manhattan or like San
Francisco and Silicon Valley have become
and so the super intense network effects
you have in Manhattan in in Silicon
Valley can be very positive because it's
like you communicate things you get
ideas but then at some point you get a
tipping point gets crossed where it goes
it becomes more negative becomes
groupthink lemming-like behavior the
madness of crowds and my judgment is
somehow Silicon Valley is you know jump
the shark just a little bit over the
last few years that that the very things
that were positive got pushed so far
till on they actually became poisonous
yeah do you think you get more support
privately from some of your colleagues
then maybe publicly on something like
that like where people other CEO is
calling you and going you know I get it
- I'm having trouble hiring qualified
people because of all of absolutely
there's an economic there look a whole
bunch of reasons there the you know the
the the the the reductionist economic
reason that things have gotten less
desirable and silicon has gotten too
expensive you know if it's $2,000 for
one bedroom apartment maybe that's like
a boomtown and that's showing things are
going well if it's $4,000 that's like
just a crazy tax right maybe should
think twice about paying yeah and so so
yes I think that yeah even on the nuts
and bolts if you're if you're starting a
new company you know five six years
though it was clear intact that Silicon
Valley was the right place to do it
because of all the network effects and
had more capital and more talent and
that that sort of helped today I think
it's much more ambiguous doesn't mean
it's all gonna move to LA or all you
move some other place
I think things gonna be much more
decentralized you know and it is it is
actually you know one of the very
strange ironies or paradoxes of the
Internet age that it was supposed to the
internet was supposed to eliminate the
tyranny of place yeah and and that it
almost almost all of it happened in this
in the scenario of Silicon Valley area
you know there's a remember there's a
talk I gave at Stanford University or a
panel discussion in - back in 2005 and
one of the questions was where will we
find the next Google so it was a student
audience the student union in Stanford
and was sort of a and so there they were
interested in working for the next
Google companies it was a search problem
they're searching for the next Google
can't type into the Google search engine
but it's really valuable to figure it
out yeah
and I sort of thought it sort of clever
slightly cryptic answer I gave was you
know I think there's a 50% chance the
next Google is within a five-mile radius
of this room so it's so I'm narrowing
the search problem five mile radius was
about maybe roughly a millionth of the
surface area of the earth so he's
reducing it by a factor of a million
still pretty hard a lot of garages and
things you have to look at within a
five-mile radius and I think that was
actually right who was that concentrated
so Wow you know the next Google was
Facebook and it was one point eight
miles from that rat and so you know I
didn't realize it at the time but that
was it was correct if I had to give the
same speech today it would be it would
be way less than 50% within 50 miles
Wow and so I think I think it is going
to be much more decentralized so yeah
the consensus is total centralization
and just as with AI and crypto I'd be
more in the crypto than the AI side in
general I mean I'd be much more on the
decentralization than centralization
side so I know you haven't been here for
that long but do you think that there's
been any costs that
you maybe didn't expect like that
there's something going on there still
there's some still still some spark of
something that maybe you won't have
access to enough or be around as much or
something like that you think there's
any risk there you know I think I think
I'll have access to the same the same
set of things but I think I think I
think I think it's just getting a little
the outsider perspective is healthy yeah
you know and and you know when we when
we initially set up my office we were
you know in San Francisco which was a
little bit outside of Silicon Valley for
many years so so I always think you want
to be you want to be you know you want
to be not in the middle of the insanity
you don't want to be totally in the
boonies gonna be somewhere in between or
and and I don't I don't think la is
totally in the boonies all right well
where I live might be but you know all
right okay so one more for ya so you
know I've been on this tour with Jordan
Peterson for the last couple months and
you know I'm it's so interesting because
I go online all day and there's people
yelling at each other and seemingly
hating each other and then I spend my
nights with thousands of people who are
coming together over ideas who may
disagree on this or that but really want
to find some answers so as someone one
of the few people now that I think is is
trying to find answers that is actually
making sense that that really wants to
look at different ways to solve the
problems of the day for the young people
that are watching this you know take
anyone under 30 that's watching this and
wants to feel hopeful because that's the
other part that I think is changing
there's a huge amount of people that
don't feel hopeful for the future they
feel our political establishment is just
at a at odds they feel this constant
hate online for those people that want
to feel hopeful what do you what can you
give them that they can look to for a
hopeful future well it's it's always
hard it's always really hard to give you
know it's always really hard to give
generic advice and I I'm not going for
generic know I always have so many
things you can say that just sound like
you know like BS in a way and that's so
that's why this is actually a simple but
difficult question yeah a very hard
question away I think um you know the
autobiographical part I I tell about
my history was that you know I was I was
super tracked you know it's like eighth
grade junior high school yearbook when
my friend says you know they're gonna
give him to Stanford in four years four
years later I get him to stand for to
get into Stanford Law School I end up at
a top-tier law firm in Manhattan and it
was you know when these places on the
outside everybody wanted to get in on
the inside everybody wanted to get out
and and the sort of the sort of a
quarter life crisis I've never had a
midlife crisis but it may be a quarter
life crisis in my mid-20s and the
quarter life crisis was you know why did
I end up in this what did I do and I
think it was that I I just followed the
track and I wasn't thinking about you
know why I was doing things what I was
doing and and and I think that's that's
sort of that's the generic advice is
that the tracks are not working maybe
they maybe they work I think they work
better in the past they had problems but
they worked better they worked they
stopped working for Gen X they're
working even less well for Millennials
or Gen Z or whatever is next mm-hmm and
it's it's it's it's and so it's more
important than ever to to think for
yourself to find something you're good
at
you're interested in you're motivated at
and and do it
the you know the again the generic this
thing of somewhat will actually just
cross the board advice I always have is
not to be overly competitive that the
you know the tracks forced you to
compete who you compete you win you
cycle and repeat and and you need to
find something where you know you're not
always just looking at the people around
you and you have some some other
reference point you know this sort of
more of a religious cut on this but I'm
always struck by how on you know the ten
commandments there they're sort of their
kind of the the first and last in some
sense are maybe the the important ones
at the end and one's the first one is
you should only look to God there's only
one God you should worship Him mm-hmm
and then the last one is you shouldn't
covet anything that belongs to your
neighbor
or and so that you shouldn't look at the
people around you too much and and so we
need to find some way to look up to look
not to look around because when we look
around it it's it's not that we figure
out what we what to do it just ends up
being the hyper copycat the medic crazed
environment and that's uh so it's always
there needs to be more of a you need to
find some transcendence I think this is
you know this is what this is what's
powerful about the Petersons message
it's no it can't just be fashion it
can't just be what everybody thinks
because that's just uh you're gonna
you're just going to be competing with
people like crazy yeah there's a literal
metaphor here and that we're always
looking down on our phones while you're
telling us to look up sort of yeah yeah
we we're always we're looking to much of
the people around us and we're you know
and and and it's it can be efficient it
can be a shortcut and then at some point
it can just be a trap because you know
if it's it's like that you know there's
a business school example I often give
where in think of a business Harvard
Business School or any of these business
schools as hothouse environments which
you have a bunch of people they have no
transcendent reference point they they
they have no idea what they want to do
they're all sort of extroverted they all
spend two years talking to each other
about what to do they don't have any
ideas and there's almost a dynamic where
you end up with the most faddish that
I'm the most wrong idea being though a
consensus choice for for so many of
these people and that's that's always a
dynamic to to try to avoid yeah I don't
know how to end an interview better than
that I'm so glad that we finally got to
do this you know I was thinking before I
sat down with you where do I point
people to with Peter Thiel and I could
point them to your companies and
everywhere else but then I thought you
know what the guys only tweeted once and
that's probably the best place I could
point people to because these days
everyone's fighting on Twitter and you
only tweeted one time so I look at the
camera follow Peter on the Twitter at
Peter Thiel unless you want me to point
them somewhere else that's okay that's
okay
my friend thank you very much all right
thanks a lot
[Music]